et pour en parler nous sommes avec
franck papazian co président du conseil
de coordination des organisations
arméniennes de france bonsoir franck
papazian merci d'être avec nous pour
débattre jérôme lambert vice président
du groupe d'amitié parlementaire france
azerbaïdjan bonsoir avoue jérôme lambert
merci d'être là également on a vu la
réaction arménienne après la
confirmation du cessez le feu une foule
en colère qui a envahi le siège du
gouvernement arménien hier soit on parle
de souffrance de goût amer est ce que
ces arméniens vont accepter ce cessez le
feu selon vous franck papazian
nous attendons un cessez le feu ou
plutôt l'arrêt dès l'arrêt l'arrêt de
l'arrêt forcé effectivement de cette
résistance des arméniens contre
l'azerbaïdjan soutenu par la turquie et
les ja liste comme une véritable
injustice
le laser vert jean a entamé une guerre
violente avec beaucoup de moyens contre
les arméniens du haut-karabakh et
l'arménie le 27 septembre dernier
ils ont été soutenus parce que les
milliards de dollars d'armements qui ont
été accumulées depuis plus de 25 ans par
laser belge en et n'était pas suffisant
ils ont appelé au secours
la turquie deuxième puissante l'otan qui
elle même a appelé au secours 2010 à 10
des terroristes qui sont venus de syrie
pour faire la guerre à l'arménie aux
arméniens du haut-karabakh pour mettre
la main sur ce territoire arménien
depuis des millénaires et qui a été
attribué par staline à l'azerbaïdjan en
1921 et donc nous considérons
effectivement que cette victoire de
l'azerbaïdjan de la turquie des
terroristes djihadistes donc de
dictature contre la démocratie
arménienne laisse un goût amer
c'est une victoire injuste le monde
entier regrettera en fait d'avoir laissé
faire en deux
ben ce qu'il appelait ses pairs en 1915
parce que si effectivement les combats
se continuaient
et bien nous aurions pu assister à de
nouveaux massacres des arméniens en 2020
alors l'histoire n'est pas puni les
rapports de force évoluent ces
territoires sont arméniens et ils
reviendront un jour parce que nous
sommes conscients et nous sommes
convaincus que un jour effectivement le
monde rendra justice et reconnaîtra son
énorme son nom de son erreur pardon
jérôme lambert vous comprenez ces propos
on sent quand même effectivement il ne
s'en cache pas les arméniens ils parlent
de souffrance 1 aujourd'hui vous
comprenez les propos de franck papazian
je peux comprendre l'émotion de nos
compatriotes français qui pour autant d
origine 1 minute mais c'est vrai que
nous sommes au lendemain d'un accord
nous sommes au lendemain d'un changement
profond pour cette région la restitution
des territoires que l'arménie elle-même
avait conquis 1 dans les débuts des
années 90 le haut karabagh faisons
partie de ces territoires mais le haut
karabagh me représentant finalement que
par un très minoritaire des des
territoires conquis deux entre 90 et 93
donc nous sommes au lendemain de cet
accord c'est vrai que compte tenu de la
propagande qui avait été conduit mais la
propagande il y en a toujours dans les
deux toutous les camps qui disait que
les forces qui défend des ces
territoires étaient qu'on passe de
l'emporter
évidemment je comprends le choc que
finalement d'une certaine façon
l'arrêt des combats la reddition et
finalement le retour des territoires à
l'azerbaïdjan je comprends que ce que ce
char soit assez profond
lorsqu'il a dû surprendre beaucoup
d'arméniens qui croyaient en la parole
de leur gouvernement
mais finalement que doit-on tirer tout
ça il ya eu 93 des résolutions du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui ont
clairement dit qu'elle était le droit
vigueur qui ont clairement dit à qui
appartenaient ces territoires conquis
par l'armée ni la résolution 884 en
particulier qui cite le haut karabagh
bien aujourd'hui depuis 25 ans plus
exactement le groupe de minsk dont
chacun dû entendre parler avait pour
mission de trouver des conditions
d'application de résolution de l'onu
mais depuis 25 ans malheureusement parce
que tout aurait été différent si ça
avait été possible
eh bien depuis 25 ans lui la paix n'a
pas fait du tout progrès parce que les
négociations n'ont absolument pas
avancer alors moi déjà deux reprises en
2016 et cet été en 2020 j'avais écrit
aux différents présidents de la
république françois hollande
emmanuel macron pour leur signifier que
la situation commençait à être
problématique puisque le peuple
azerbaïdjanais ses dirigeants et le
peuple azerbaïdjanais
attendez attendez à ce que le droit
international soit appliqué
il est arrivé cet été maintenant que
exactement il est arrivé que ben les
armes mouvement à nouveau parler et
finalement heureusement aujourd'hui et
cette salle dont on doit se réjouir la
paix a été à nouveau haïti conclu
faut-il que cette paix effectivement
maintenant puisse se réaliser dans de
bonnes conditions
oui on va voir revenir on va laisser la
parole à franck papazian cet accord sous
l'égide de la russie
jérôme lambert faisaient légion groupe
de minsk clairement franck papazian
c'est un échec aujourd'hui du travail
effectué par le groupe de mythes injuste
c'est une péninsule le valide le tracé
des frontières et un p 1 et donc
gratuitement le droit à l'eau pose la
question de l'intangibilité des
frontières établies par staline en 1921
outre le droit à l'autodétermination des
peuples qui est un concept de gauche au
camp de monsieur lambert devrait plutôt
consacrer le la question du droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes puisque
je pense qu'il est socialiste
alors que la question de l'intangibilité
des frontières tracées par staline
sincèrement j'aurais un peu honte de
défendre ça sur un ton un temps de
défendre ça j'aurai un plant également
de défendre laser médian est une
dictature farouche qui est 168ème sur
180 dans le classement mondial de la
liberté de la presse et qui aujourd'hui
un état corrompu
c'est un état guerrier est un état qui a
accumulé l'armement militaire depuis 20
ans 25 ans et monsieur à liège le
prétend de la république de la servette
gens que vous rejoignez visiblement
demain monsieur lambert puisque vous
allez à bas coût de main a dit j'avais
dit qu'on chasserait les arméniens de
notaire comme des chiens et nous l'avons
fait est ce que monsieur lambert vous
cautionnez ses propos du président de la
république d'azerbaïdjan
jérôme lambert vatra réponse moi je
regrette les paroles qui sont prononcés
ce soin n'est pas seulement ce soin je
suis attentif à tout ce qui se dit
depuis la signature de cet accord et je
constate que malgré tout surtout en
france derrière un sur deux en france
bien sûr quelques centaines aussi de
manifestants à erevan
mais surtout en france des français
finalement continue la propagande comme
si finalement la guerre ne devrait pas
cesser la guerre à cesser la guerre a
cessé le droit international et des
revenus
alors maintenant que ce soit le tel ou
tel régime dans tel ou tel pays vous
savez le droit international
à partir du moment où le conseil de
sécurité 10 avec l'accord de la france
derrière 17 et ri thouars appartiennent
à l'azerbaïdjan ils appartiennent en
azerbaïdjan c'est pas staline qui a
décidé ça c'est le conseil de sécurité
des nations unies et voilà donc c'est le
droit international moderne qui résulte
des décisions prises aujourd'hui par le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je vous réponde à ça
c'est la réalité tout simplement sur la
lazio
oui oui vas toi oui alliés est-ce que
vous cautionnez les propos d' alien et
demain à coup qu'il y avait dit j'avais
dit qu'on chasserait les amis un de nos
terres comme des chiens et nous l'avons
pèse que vous cautionnez ça monsieur
lambert j'ai pas cautionner ou pas
cautionner je suis je j'entends bien que
au lendemain de l'accord beaucoup
d'arméniens comme sans doute beaucoup
d'azerbaïdjanais sont dans une forme je
dirais soit d'extrême déception soit
d'extrême faurie et que j'imagine que
leurs propos je l'espère en tout cas
dépasse en quelque sorte leur pensée il
faut maintenant travailler à la paix et
c'est pas avec de tels discours qu'on va
y arriver
ni les vôtres oui ce que je peux
entendre aussi de lapins de quelques
azerbaïdjanais dont le sial yves que
j'étais surpris qu'ils qui considèrent
les arméniens comme des chiens c'est pas
d'ailleurs l'explication c'est que c'est
pas les arméniens mais c'est des troupes
arméniennes qui occupent le territoire
azerbaïdjanais mais enfin peu importe
peu importe je n'aime pas entendre
simple mais aujourd'hui la question
n'est pas là la question c'est est ce
qu'on veut de la paix ou pas rentable
est justement ce que vous voulez de la
paix aujourd'hui malgré la déception et
l'amertume clairement nous voulons il
rompait sur les territoires les
arméniens vivre en paix les arméniens
d'arménie grand paix sur les territoires
ils sont les leurs c'est la paix qui a
été imposée la porte des canons est ta
puissance militaire de l'azerbaïdjan est
de la turquie est une baie un juste ces
territoires appartiennent aux arméniens
depuis des millénaires ils sont volés
aujourd'hui par l'azerbaïdjan et la
turquie et les dialyses
on doit condamner ça on ne peut pas
accepter effectivement ça quand vous
parlez nous droit international la
france dit se tenir ou des d'arménie à
laquelle elle a renouvelé son amitié
elle a tout de même comme l'a dit jérôme
lambert a prouvé ces événements
finalement vous sentez abandonné
aujourd'hui par par la france où on
passe les sensations permettez moi qui
revient ces thèmes gainsbourg à franck
pape a dit elle et moi je sais mais mais
avoue partir sur une base son plus clair
de son gardien de déterminer de décider
quelle terre leur appartient parce
qu'après tout un monde à part égale des
arméniens en iran il ya des arméniens en
russie il ya des arméniens en turquie à
des arméniens des millions d'arméniens
autour de l'arménie et toutes ces terres
là ou alors j'y comprends plus rien je
n'approuve pas ce discours
toute cette terre-là n'appartiennent pas
à l'arménie ce sont des traités
internationaux
ce sont surtout des décisions du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu qui fixe le droit
le droit samedi en la volonté de dieu
c'est tsl et l'histoire et les
frontières effectivement est allé on
peut pas régler en 10 minutes le fond de
votre problème qui qui qui qui semble
perdurer
en tout cas c'est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
vous sentez sont nous tout simplement
on vous seul nous pensons que la coupe
de l'international a commis une grave
erreur qu'elle regrette pas elle se
rendra compte dans quelques années
monsieur lambert sand raconte lui même
si je pense que les choses peuvent
changer peuvent continuer à évoluer
parce que les rapports de force évoluent
et nous les arméniens ne renoncerons
jamais à ces terres qui sont arménienne
allez-y monsieur lambert dans le
haut-karabakh nous verrez les centaines
d'églises ou verrez les monastères vous
verrez effectivement tous les lieux de
vie en fait ils ont animé l'histoire de
l'arménie durant des millénaires
allez-y et peut-être que vous reviendrez
en ayant changé d'avis parce
qu'aujourd'hui opel nous assistons à la
prise en otage des arméniens haut
karabakh qui ne peuvent pas vivre à
portée de canon
en fait de l'azerbaïdjan puisse que
l'azerbaïdjan a massacré les arméniens
durant des dizaines d'années
et puis également à la fin des années 80
et au début des années 90
l'azerbaïdjan a imposé une guerre à
l'arménie que l'arménie a gagné en 1994
et depuis 1994 l avenue les vous parler
du droit international l'azerbaïdjan a
violé le cessez-le-feu entre 6000 et 10
mille fois par an alors c'est
inacceptable ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
est inacceptable c'est injuste la
communauté internationale s'est trompée
elle a cédé à la force et canon et des
pétrodollars de l'azerbaïdjan soutenu
par la turquie
c'est pas correct ce n'est pas bien
merci à tous les deux ans reprend vous
vous croirez n'y a pas eu d'accord et
que la propagande continue il faut faire
la paix maintenant
c'était effectivement le sujet de notre
débat initial la paix peut-elle tout de
même selon bert si vous partez plein en
azerbaïdjan pour fêter la victoire de
l'azerbaïdjan bravo merci à tous les
deux en tout cas franck papazian et
jérôme lambert d'avoir accepté ce débat
merci à vous deux